so if if you have a
a spiritual mentor today
because everything has been modernized
they're usually a lecturer they talk
and you listen and you think
okay
it is a modern corruption
talking thinking
is not the way
the mind that is sick cannot cure itself
it's a dead end
so what we're doing
is a pre-modern way
you come into the mind
through the body
okay because and this is possible
because of the body-mind unification
okay
but it's not quite the mind
it's just different enough
that
it doesn't get corrupted the way the
sick mind just makes more sick mind okay
so
in my movement
i should be able to demonstrate
communion
and a reconciliation of dichotomy so
right now i there's a physical hymn and
a physical me
so maybe he goes you're here
you're fighting him and you do the same
technique
shove him down
and get on
and here it looks society
but there are things you need to look
for
the dichotomous mind cannot move at the
speed of life
so it shows up
in gaps
and in delays
and in staccato-like movement
that create the gaps okay because he's
not falling staccato-like you see he
just falls at once
so the other thing to note
is that inside his movement there is
always a hidden space
and i always step into the in space
when i have a dichotomous relationship
with him i always try to overpower him
and i always move into the young space
through more young and it's incorrect
okay
so the same the same movement
instead of this one stopping him and
then get ready to make him go again
i just use the same movement he's going
do you see
and this step here that we're using as a
kind of trip
i just step because there's yin there
and he'll go around
so he's coming in and he's going around
me
he's going around
same exact thing
and i try to reduce this gap
so as we watch
the chest to chest space that's going
here
i try to get rid of it asap
then i try to get rid of the secret
there's the knot this the not this and
that and i just go to one thing
one
and you can see it starts to become
spiral
it stops being
x y grid path
okay
let's try to get these
so
[Music]
bye